al-bashir bhutto may seem like a typical
young boy
but at the age of 10 he is already the
philippines chess prodigy
he improves his skills on manila
sidewalks
mostly in the streets of chiapo where
older
avid chess players like him meet to pass
the time
here he beats veteran players with the
mastery and position
rarely seen from young chess players
like him
even pulling a draw with master player
chito garmin
al-bashar will go far if he gets the
right support the support from the
government is crucial
he needs to be exposed more to get
better
was six when he started competing
internationally
he has played in iran china and malaysia
and for so many muslims here who have
long felt discriminated against
in a country where they are a minority
al-bashir
is a source of pride people here tell us
al-bashar's story
mirrors their own aspirations a young
filipino muslim
making it to the global stage because of
sheer talent and determination
in competitions i always work hard to
make it worthwhile for my parents and
those who supported me
the best part about chess is winning but
losing is good too because you learn
more
but there are struggles back home
albasha comes from a poor family who
moved from marawi city in the southern
philippines
a place held back by war and
displacement
his parents have often struggled to make
ends meet
so paying for al-basher's training has
proven to be difficult
despite his classes and online
competition he still has to share a
laptop with five other siblings
my home it is the only house i have but
i put it on collateral to help fund some
of his training
it's not easy but al-bashir is give from
god so we have to support him
he is set to compete in the feed the
online world cadets and youth rapid
championship this week
and although his weak internet
connection at home may cost him critical
minutes in the game
al-bashir remains confident like so many
prodigies before him
he says his chess pieces have given him
a sense of purpose
and hopefully a way out of poverty jamal
alindogan al jazeera manila